dian pour les étudiants en médecine et
en pharmacie
c'est une de tout comme pour tous les
étudiants de france et une prise de
conscience collective de leurs forces
ils ont pris conscience qu'ils pouvaient
se poser en interlocuteur valable et sur
le plan médecine les étudiants de par ce
fait je pense qu'ils peuvent et doivent
réclamer un enseignement
universitaire valable ils travaillent
pour ça en commission c'est à dire que
il semaine tout de suite au travail pour
faire valoir leur pouvoir c'est à dire
demander une réforme des études
médicales et pour cela nous travaillons
en commission si vous voulez on peut
vous expliquer la marche de la machine
cette machine qui est composé d'un
comité de coordination qui essayait de
coordonner toutes les commissions et
toutes les choses qui sont ici et nous
nous faisons un journal tous les jours
nous tapons tous nos rapports de
commissions nous tapons toutes les
questions nous avons ici un cliff comité
de liaison inter fin qui relie toutes
les facultés de médecine de france afin
que nous marchions vert dans le même
mouvement et dans la même ligne et ici
j'ai un camarade qui étire prague qui a
représenté tour aux états généraux des
facultés de médecine comme eu lieu hier
à toulouse j'ai participé avec trois
camarades aux assemblées générales les
facs de médecine de toulouse nous sommes
trouvé d'accord sur tous les grands
points de la réforme je vous lire très
rapidement c'est une réforme complète
des structures hospitalières
universitaires formation médicale
pratique indispensable pour tous les
étudiants on a posé la question de la
finalité du système et de son
rattachement fac de médecine sur tous
ces points nous sommes tous d'accord et
la prochain le prochain colloque
interface se tiendra à tours dimanche et
lundi pour la semaine prochaine